And you say oh
Uh, OK,
yo
could you go to optimizes chinha
inngewa so could
you go and then shingles
kwassa.
Oh yi pata
yoka in
or quinotesojas cigar
reo
then uh train chip tangyone
is chicken hamnoti
zang ge bu
yonga ultrasobo chipipe sim
zang.
3 pepo.
customizing custom
hypo
pso check a point of shade
jia hyposo
or check a point this
training kin chuka smi.
Tekuo chun jabani shik
yogi shimbrima kuni
age on Twitter kebarapa
and to win raqua or kuyen stilcomida
yonkinangri suka immi
kibodeka teko
or ibo onso
unga agent to semi
mulon
or stika kua.
Uh, put on a
han a web bal turin kiro richungan
then or balsky debubu
teta
yongge
inside amazon kicks. Sweet.
Grigo contact center putunging
context center or agent
take a kung kunje swami
or kino a connect
to do or serginri
pangsmita yo zang in heim
pubun chronica
agent to bubune
or protio. Asian to
run in kenyamisukekatekoseke
bude or sukereresemida
chapoen menape buinen
kirue protiopojoinkiro
chayur
agent timidai kiro chayur agent
to the or putunkiro remonjo so
soogeshimbunderun request nootija
in hako krigo
or tescommandergo implicationaltebanen
ento ento hakinobu chicho
pashairmida saramike
and deo sarrame kebobshi.
Sarami yongyanghamian
suiriligon sushibiriligon a yaigawanjo
orangong gu
is a ptio agent traguan and deo de kuron
moderinkiro chaur
agent tega chapoteo kuyo
you're a balmidabo puan tam
danjanondeo
or security agent traguyo changpe
on the soda or putunkitoe
or so hasimianopuan.
chunkitoe
agent to security agent
to the tak yonge
hasim updatedmada kok ch ch
or chintu tested the bui tested makan
got koskbajima
union tang jaroinen tebobs agent
in bobs agent.
Oh
AS I.
Claudai Tainarerigo
moduli teitao you know monitoring
obviously yongere hasimian
or bunjega singo steam chu
xi larigo change one in bunzo
or or tochori energy irongo
pun anechoasuke and you know wan
zhong kwong agent timidayques or tonche
push. uh
Or bus
or the stride yongyang
ham chong hongi
optika kuo sang bush
duba
or do you say they got ban
the mode son
and he said there's all right doba 2
pro could they go um moderbasoni.
Could you go or
or or multimodal hain
multimodal buddin
or unique angwan
mangoba baba
yon ki mopani
kisshiki
is bus.
the training. s
crypto devices.
Students kajakun chang ship
rangomida wee bush
or kutua chombu indeo boderi monji
kurrigo tur chronica
degasuko in the MCPD tiun in kabonjimjamian
arazo or je agent tikapirohan
turu tangyazosunida reso
bushinanggocha pujapan.
I yonzukwa kombungiguyonge
iron Asian tick uinina
and immune session at the murkinen
hukun pujapanwakupimong
kutukajangikansuna demida.
agent
in the cirlimiware agent.
Taste or agent
kuduira or
agent kuru yonga shimian jangi
kutua kanza denen yeah shinyamer
pushes sima
or maim agent ku on then.
Sushia
proto yang peteguo
joke ura
uniron panangguita.
Well, immihio is pushing
and cha chilgoke budurichegogi
sondeohana shi agent
to kuturo manderoso chilchero
kudongi in a long time.
Could you go Mwagaten
or chadogropalihejunen kwei.
Could you go in the tangi mem
memory. Could
you go or
injung inga kander hankobbone chanan
identify
identity could you go iboungo hankopbo
bonioringhau tibogging
her sin
or agent to call observability.
Chukaru chacheraozpayson
kuduaga pako hang kpretoa
kung mouldiri
isosmida yogikaji
or teron kenya mi chukaka tenandeo
chapoenviebuhi ketu
kotaos polish and kenya
mimida or bec
uh beka on kino teeny tisano shiman
nomun. Pyongge humble din
chadohajimbaran teak
te
or chartish onso
sushigomidari go hamboulon
eya ye kolgamurunihue
sauwalikayo or to kur they
they bebon to keibelu
Asian ha pumjwalihanen.
tangi tam 00
tangi episodic
functionality.
task
to go or could you go agent agent to yoke
could you go unmoduro
or agent bands.
jet boost
jaye or agent. The,
uh, Samsungja, it makes us up,
uh, Samsungja, it makes us up with a chi a jiro
uh cloudu yeah pyungaku
Pyongyang Johnson will be bargetaduin
pun uh sarero.
The Samsung Samsung Samsung or
yo. Pyong
Pyongyongyang is hang yang ching the sanyang
ok yayoi
man and Pyongyangi ching.
I. Uh,
yay.
Pyong and Pyong and you will hear.
Um and then you look at punching
it so
you don't have uh
project the project to or you don't kmina
uh you don't. There's
a gas
chains pins the pyong techokpa
pyonghua shale
and there ish sanyan a chi
project shalekuya.
Oh, abso
sun so
give you a
majima and then we'll put the you told me yeah you
got. But
so you got you and uh you
don't. So
just uh
unique unique banjo
guru uh pum pumer
uh so cloud the saboye
yo chunyon and transjections through utunnanojunge
uni. Uh,
chin and krifuka is
uh kuma.
Oh, punching and you don't whakaajection
down pun pungi
I'm punchunjection
down pun. Uh,
punching
store. There's
a pix pixi pix there's a unique so
you got pins jacket on uh on
there. or
Pyong chinga or injection mic
uh wa
uh ribi chokyong tame uh
on either hau
or don't. Or stashian
punching you're
gonna take I think and there uh pungi chinga nikaika's
a transaction sugar pungi
comes on you don't. The
transjectionsu run now I don't punika and
uh transjections you think.
So you don't, she's not literally take a power miri
midi take a a
scale in scale
or and
then scale in I mean so
uh unicosa wu yang.
the six
jumps up for. Oh,
you don't you don't think you don't do the architectural.
Pinosse choyongan architecturega aka
abso pyongnimi
puyain agent to qua stands
a educator yo so agent
architecture of pungu hekuya so architecture
sekaji uh yang yin
and there are uh agent to quite a
long time bubu
choye agent hunjaun
in and then they get agent focus on this
uh archipan and data collector agent
too uh shade chili.
Tapiohan analyze agent
Grigu corridor geo tangjante
tapiano uh chaduroso chichanen
a research agent Grigu orchestrate
to agent you don't tayang and
uh unwteocharuquetri tahanan
agent 3 so.
They agent then,
uh, agent to quite a long time
that may be taun so you got
uh taju kun sang
you got a kabu
bu
pedi biwa hanjang
ha ibubu. Uh,
uh, uh, architecture. to
agent agents.
Uh, tearu
pinaku pungge is or hinges hongba
because I mean rote pungi
or y architecture and
nje multi agent architecture and I
obsessed we are
you on a bon frames
or ko kn agent to qua
picture. Talmon
uh pananggu massim agent
multi agent to u architecture haji go temurri
one and there e temo and teitan and stemurs
and tea
uh inhada. You
then spe
uh agent
or or.
Uh, you renew
the service we don't service pyong pure titanium
you don't go through.
you go. Uh,
you can. The 21 channelsorroge
service repikki hao
kachi or araina Spio
or take it in chi han yo chi
chi togeo
ge service repigu.
You done both together. Service
spirit and
then uh corniman
and a
system. I
mean. to
be a low or it's.
You're gonna get. I
come up rods
or chine jang man and you don't
yu take a punch they saw june
uh and popa don't. To
the we've done a pub uh chong
chin or uh
Change fiction
and cloudsang Pyongyang they're gonna
cloudia or to get them and then cloud
the architecture chuck
you don't. I'm
a cloud the chang when you need
a tangga passing analysis
forgeo or you
don't care whatso or
pu pan
pan richmond
to tangia
you don't. You
guru uh cloud
and then you get ching 3
piggy passing on there you don't go to
uh detection has a chang.
So you
don't diction,
you don't uses the sim
you go to monitoring is Judina and on there you
don't go to a.
You're on the sing you a petemada
kizhong petangwataruge
or the
people mm.
Or
cloud cloud tango cloud
agent to pin
agent architecture boo.
security agent
agent through you get so
you got you got you
don't agent.
Uh, the pins,
uh, and
leadership in pin
so so so
leadership.
Uh, uh,
so you know you go is a consumer we can, uh,
and then, uh, you don't go at all so you got.
Uh, to. Yeah
it was hang right there right
there yeah it was done I think I'll go to tell me to struggle in and there
you go in a
in a I just hang on and can win in Hangs 10
scopes me.
You get a
process in the you
you don't think I'll we will
process in the got to beat. Or
take nyongas.
It was. A pas
tata tata
pipeline Mandarin the kinjengi.
mm
stunji
ok bonswa
tajiwaki.
Majima guru uh
engineer kang chaka kiss
skunk
pungroche
uh inside duiktashita
you don't agent
to a who we look it.
or a jima
agent to nunje tai teen
or tetai yangwa.
Crystal. majimaguro
after massenger to she
uh and Johnsonga pun
in there yoga
uh intelligent cloud of.
A j
s cloud
Pyongyang.
Oh, cloud
solution toy through pung
pins. And
just to talk to cloud
it's a cloud system which will aim
to touch people religion and you got to quit the menu in there you don't want people.
Uh, you don't go to hug to ban.
Uh, it's here
so kakozo. uh
kaka uh
trip. They
was on Kakao talks all this kumam
type people uh kakao
togem uneny skub
uh such procedure uh could you sillibu's
g.
How do we are is terabyte,
uh, some girls it jumps out ter petabyte.
Could you rega kaka yoka k
kun jagiku. Pa
looks on the she's.
K kako
kumbukums uh
to to
shi uh elasticso chiki pyongyang is
a. Uh, chrometo
yes queso kaka sugar
sim it's done
tegu'm telling guo gwang is
hung a simit.
Uh. Oh
taka los to tang suga
cheagiso.
Do do do you close to the case because it's how your sin
you don't talk to the 10 watching the indexinga
losing tens one to get them
you don't talk up today don't to do.
Uh, kin.
Haji sugar
to kick
and sim.
Oh bat or kijo and the choli changy
is or kebaga changi.
It kebajane guri bogiwe song lokinakibanahame
and the tiko
because I'm a beritohagena they get the kurappanakatun
shi the databasewe
teshiboduomita.
Oh. You
don't. pandemic.
No, it's done to span or er
or telemetry
tetore
chai patasinchoz so he sim.
Oh
kaika
or bastok or click
clicks
and then punyon be well.
Oh, je yongyang
and then I. Observability
and take it with a simita to kick
the plexiga.
peta. and
you know. Oh
it's done.
Chechiwe
family chinan then it's
a city data so uh Pon Johnson uh
gamasin then
ucheng. Kiriak
again tele bug on
Asian tuna because you don't the Asian proto tape
to the don't know a
song or shoe or. or
watching shins
telemeter. Uh.
Who need cholo litezokibujo
guru or chang tangji ham
changi kuganepaa changi in
the pen uh pun to the bus.
Pres the pan
uh architecture
architecture. Oh,
she's she's pipe
in the bush kaka
kaka in the pan.
architecture.
Oh, you look in the top 10, the cup 20.
Uh. the
architectural. Uh.
Oh kong
kayong via
click puno kuka.
And. Pyong.
tested. how
do you kilter.
Oh, you. or
It. kaka.
Uh, one.
Could you go
cooking and they go. Clikos
1 millimeter clikos
to be
bus
or tea. to
download shi.
I I
give you. Could
you go how
do we sushi.
Tai chi chang
pikimoebuni
pi. The
processor. To.
Oh, OK, then I'm a pegan click to the
color oriented tb in there color oriented tha
so can ika
toungeo. I'm
I'm she knows. The
tangi
tangji changi kuka
changi kajjj.
in production at all in bat
joke so obviously tenna
or in inside all this in then kunbuchet
click.
Could you go uh
to to the context to the.
so The
and then so she's 10
again so we. The.
Oh, in the production shi
took service the production. I'm
I'm gonna do uh chang then ma.
Protogan is a Chinese ching.
You know man so business inside to the boodosiska
it is a test that happened in there.
So this is. She's
a pet.
You. in.
The. Kijoni
yes or
ka kayongyuba this is say in there close talk is buskijo
yes so you could get close to critical
hange close to sim.
Oh, you can skela
also there in the index.
Could. Click
on them paikoshi giga
king compet skir
buoysen.
Cardio
index you got kalita and kajong
so and the tests pushing. critical.
OK. tele
telemeter pipe
in a kukui
telemetry metric.
contest. and
the bana takaya bacha
durinhana shibu.
want. To
x to the queso
queso tibeloo
chang the ponz
tanjia sinkaji kabu
queso yon. Yeah.